quand est ce que vous allez arrêter de
m'amuser de me surprendre je vous le
demande
avant-hier je me baladais dans les
mentions twitter parce que je regardais
les retours et ce que j'en fait dire à
propos des deux clips hit de l'été ou
vos manches dans cette vidéo on n'est
que trois jours après et comme on a
bossé dessus pendant un mois avant que
ça sorte bas je lis chaque retour chaque
phrase chaque insulte je la lui ai je la
savoure et je vous entre deux messages
qui disent que miradors et mieux que
quelqu'un s'est amusé à rt et femmes
tweet à moi qui date de 2012
et je me dis non mais quel truc de
bâtard aller piocher dans des tweets de
2012 2011 des tweets que j'ai fait quand
j'avais 15 ans quand je voyais twitter
un peu comme un journal intime
une manière de dire ce qu'on pense de
s'évader d'être franc de se confesser
alors je n'ai pas du tout l'endroit pour
mais bon la vraie vie et pas ou alors on
se confesse jamais alors on le fait sur
twitter c'était une époque différente
c'était vraiment le début de tout et on
peut même pas site et des tweets et où à
l'époque j'avais vraiment oublié
effectivement je suis sur twitter depuis
huit ans depuis 2011
et du coup il doit y avoir des sacrés
perles s'en est donc suivi cette idée
qui est de découvrir ces vieux tweet que
j'ai fait quand j'avais 15 16 ans et
pour cela j'ai demandé à lucioles de me
trouver les 50 meilleurs les 50 plus
pertinent pour cette vidéo et je vais
les découvrir en même temps que vous
aujourd'hui et je pense ça va être un
moment à la fois amusant et fourie qui
est très désagréable commençons par le
commencement les deux premiers twitts
c'est parti pour twitter bon par contre
va falloir que je me fasse a twitté
c'est vraiment le tweet d'un gars qu'à
15 ans c'est génial s'ensuit un tweak le
lendemain qui dit déjà six abonnés à
cette heure-là incroyable mais vous
faites pas des pâtes à 1h30 petite
boutade à vous de la comprendre
huit ans après la comprendre c'est très
compliqué je pense cette vente liée à ma
bio twitter qui est j'aime faire des
batailles de rémy du bateau un truc
comme ça je ne sais pas si quelqu'un a
la réponse à cette boutade huit ans
après qu'il la partage avec nous tous
écoutez moi je trouve ça carrément moi
je trouve ça car je trouve qu'on est
déjà suggéré qu'ils gèrent très bien son
image qui va devenir un community
manager de légende c'est faux je twitte
uniquement pour diriger une nouvelle
vidéo en ligne avec mirador est tous là
récemment j'avoue j'ai dû faire un
effort j'ai fait pas mal de toutes et
tous en ce moment je réponds dans ma
loge ont d'ailleurs mais je fais pas de
tweet pour exprimer des ma pensée mais à
l'époque tu en es gt gt bon j'étais
meilleur panon le 15 janvier 2002 en
voilà une autre encore plus épique xd
qu'est ce que les vieux même oh là là ça
me rappelle des souvenirs incroyables
duo tout le monde j'ai squeeze je dois
avouer qu'aujourd'hui je suis un peu
fatigué ah oui c'est une vidéo dans
laquelle je disais ça sur la chaîne
secondaire à l'extrême un an
bravo clément de l'avoir trouvée
félicitations une photo de moi avec une
cigarette fatigué bien sûr à
sous-entendu n'y avait pas que du tabac
déjà me revoir une cigarette à la main
c'est horrible
il est vrai j'ai eu une période où
j'étais fumeurs et ouais même squeeze à
fumer pour se donner un style essex ma
photo facebook et des gens l'avaient
trouvé je me sois y avait eu un petit
débat sur sa genre oh la la il fume au
mont dieu et maintenant je ne fume plus
et c'est vrai que je fais mais brandon
roy d'un ce type j'ai toujours trouvé ça
désagréable de frites c'est vraiment je
suis l'exemple parfait du gaa
influençable ne soyez pas comme moi
soyez résistant est bon de fumer assez
idiot 16 heures aujourd'hui
franchement ça me fait absolument rien
je m'en fous totalement vivement 18 ans
accepte d'être jeune et innocent lucas
accepte le plutôt que de rêver d'avoir
la majorité pour te sentir enfin bien
arrête je voulais vraiment me donner un
style mais c'est vrai que j'ai eu
beaucoup de temps beaucoup d'années à me
trouver et je pense qu'il ya des gens
parmi eux se trouve sur le toit dans
cette phase on se cherche et du coup je
suis je disait des trucs comme ça pour
me donner un style mais je pensais pas
du tout ce que je disais c'est bon juste
pour faire le mec faire le gars stylet
parce que je considérais que c'était le
gars stylet qui disait ça alors que pas
du tout déjà 30 city state merci
beaucoup les gens je pense que ça ira
existait le traumatisme né dislike à
l'époque j'avais la règle des 1% je me
souviens si j'avais plus de 1% que
j'aime pas j'étais trop pas bien je
dormais match je me disais oh là là je
suis vraiment du tout ça me mettait
vraiment mal aujourd'hui j'attends des
10% et je m'envole j'ai mis du temps
mais j'ai réussi à accepter le fait que
des fois bien compris ne plaît pas des
fois t'es à côté de la plaque
et c'est comme ça et j'ai mis des années
d amener à accepter ça et là vous voyez
j'étais en plein dans le déni je pense
que ça ira est visé mais en vrai c'est
vraiment bon ça ira là vous arrêter
c'est bon j'ai compris
oh la vache alors 2002 je vous jure je
suis fan d'iron man
si tu savais lucas si je savais dans ma
prochaine vidéo je vous présenterai les
t-shirts squeeze mdrr lorraine vers
quelque chose de mam une annexe pour les
lire que je puisse cliquer qu'est-ce que
c'était le tee shirt
ok je suis pas sûr qu'en gamma games
aurait lâché les droits mais qu'est ce
que c'est moi qui coince c'est quelqu'un
qui a créé à l'époque
en tout cas je sais une chose je le veux
ça c'est que là on a dépassé les 600
milles vue je pensais qu'un jeu il y
aurait le milieu assez fou c'est
touchant à me touche ça je me revois
innocent rêver du million
et aujourd'hui toutes les vidéos font le
million but mais à l'époque pour moi
c'était tellement impensable tellement
fou et je pense que je parlais une vidéo
qui s'appelle j'aime colloque j'ai du
spray depuis pascal un des protagonistes
qui voulait plus apparaître de temps et
c'est donc je vais retirer tout
simplement mais je pense que je vais
parler de jeune colosse qui était un
buzz incroyable
en rentrant du lycée je suis passé
devant le collège en bas de ma rue comme
d'hab et quatre personnes m'ont reconnu
hashtag choqué m mes mecs c'est touchant
c'est vraiment touché en plus tard
j'avais oublié avoir toutes et tous ces
trucs
en fait je m'exclame est devant des
choses qui aujourd'hui font vraiment
partie de mon quotidien comme le
reconnaissent à des endroits où je vais
les vidéos face des millions de vu fer
j'ai le sang sans prétention quoi ça
fait partie de mon quotidien aujourd'hui
et à l'époque j'étais tellement loin de
m'imaginer commencerai ma vie sept ans
plus tard vis-à-vis de tous alors
peut-être que ça ne touche que moi mais
en tout cas c'est toujours pour moi des
coquettes plus de la béarnaise et une
canette de coca eric mais ce tweet
d'enfants là dedans au fond tout a
changé
mais en même temps rien n'a changé je me
fais toujours des coquillettes avec la
[ __ ] de sousse bernès la bénédicte à
toi même tu sais c'est incroyable quel
bonheur
quel bonheur de voir qu'il ya des trucs
qui ne changent pas quoi s'est décidé
dans la trop temporaire qu'on m'a fait
je vais mettre du banjo trop fun cet
instrument jeandebon décor en allant s
vous et 2012
en 2019 tu en as dans ton des corps
tellement tu le trouves fun hélas
beaucoup encore des coïncidences comme
ça marrant tout comme ça se passe trop
comment j'ai trop envie de faire un
podcast j'ai quelques idées mais je veux
pas faire ça sur un coup de tête
le tweet en avril 2012
et du coup j'ai pris le temps de le
faire derrière et c'était quoi que j'ai
fait c'était à oui j'avais cette tête à
un moment où je faisais les tweets comme
ça vous situer bien c'était les profs
ah oui il faut du temps pour faire bonne
case sur les braves attendait avec jets
d'expérience c'est moi je vous dis c'est
un croire que la musique influence
l'humeur des gens sans musique et la
mauvaise humeur avec musique égal au yen
à baby c'est trop mignon ce genre de
petit constat de la vie quoi ce tweet il
témoigne d'un truc c'est l'époque où je
prenais conscience de l'impact que les
choses avaient sur moi par exemple la
musique et je le dis en mode personne le
sait jean personne ne sait mais tout le
monde sait déjà baissé ça témoigne des
langues de l'innocence que tu as compter
quand et ados et jeunes et tu dois
beaucoup plus vieux et mature que tu ne
l'est vraiment comme aujourd'hui je me
vois beaucoup de matches que je suis
vraiment en vrai dans six ans ferait
caisse j'étais con squeeze 2019
vous rendez compte que dans 532 la bonne
et j'ai cent mille abonnés je suis allé
au stade de france récemment je vois ce
que ça fait c'est émouvant en fait entre
ces tweets émanant et ça a été très
progressif y ait beaucoup de chemin mais
c'est vrai que quand tu fais un cote
comme ça hop mi-temps après 12 millions
d'abonnés tu fais waouh c'est
impressionnant c'est vrai que c'est
impressionnant [ __ ] en tout cas à
plein temps chez elle au stadium de
toulouse pour un but plus beau et j'ai
eu la chance de monter sur scène
d'ailleurs est effectivement vous étiez
30 milles devant moi et c'était déjà
c'est déjà très impressionnant c'est ça
qui est dérangeant pour ma chaîne c'est
que si je fais pas d'un trou plein de
gens regarderont pas la vidéo ouah
attend quoi
si je fais pas d'intro si je dis pas eu
d'excusé ou si je vais pas une intro
comme c'était la mode à l'époque les un
truc comme ça de della à l'époque qui
est vraiment ce gimmick de faire une
intro en motion design comme ça qu'il y
aurait entre 3 et 10 secondes et de la m
avant la vidéo ça c'est un truc qui se
fait plus du tout à l'époque c'était
limite impérative quoi savez pas tout
bien trop homogènes design tt merde
alors quand vous venez ça veut rien dire
c'est juste une intro homogène design on
s'en bat les couilles nous c'est fou les
verrous psychologiques qu'on s'inflige
est comme ça en tant que tueur c'est fou
comme on enfin ils suivent des codes
sinon on n'était pas bien je sais
presque joué oasis wonderwall jusque ma
guitare n'est pas très bien encore des
il faut que ma mère fait que ça bah
écoutez je me suis arrêté là en tout cas
en terme de guitare j'ai je pense j'en
ai fait le 15 mai 2012 puis plus jamais
mais j'ai presque réussi à faire aux
audi sport north oil et ceux qui font la
guitare vous savez à quel point les
choses à faire vraiment gros lebel sa
servante plus tard j'adorerais faire des
clips de musique ou du montage vidéo en
tout cas choisir les chansons
correspondent au tèf flex est effrayant
avec la prophétie quoi c'est fou c'est
exactement ce que j'ai fait plein de
fois derrière c'est dingue c'est
touchant je suis touchée dans cette fois
dites moi j'suis pas le seul s'il vous
plaît et ben lucas sache que plus tard
tu as fait des clips de musique c'est
touchant avec c'est fou comme quoi il ya
des trucs en toi très très tôt tulle et
réalisa un moment donné ta vie est à
oublier que des années avant tu en avais
déjà envie en fait mais tu pouvais pas
tu avais pas les opportunités qui fit
qu'il faut pour pouvoir le faire et
c'est beau quoique ceux qui connaissent
les bonnes âmes style rt j'aimerais
savoir voir si vous comprendrez une
future vidéo
alors je sais ça paraît impensable mais
à un moment donné avant que ce soit
repris par tous les médias nationaux etc
n'y avait pas tant de gens qui étaient
tombés dessus
est ce que je suis vraiment en train de
défendre le mois de 2012 alors qu on
s'en bat les couilles
oui je déteste les cours c'est officiel
j'ai la preuve eu de la gueule en maths
angoua et explique toujours des trucs
aulas
je suis sûr que depuis ce tweet a été
fait au moins 400 fois par des gens du
même âge sur twitter vous l'avez
peut-être même fait vous même la callas
et didot il ya des années vous avez
oublié retourner voir vos tweets de
l'époque vous allez voir ce soir je geek
alors ça peut vous paraître ringard mais
mec quand j'avais l'opportunité le geek
est un soir donc quand ma mère sortent
et si elles sortaient pas ce dimanche
que patrick et mais quand ma mère
faisait un truc est pas un mec je suis
trop content je le tweet est carrément
je pouvais geek et je suis le seul qui
avait peur de ces foutus et hobbies
étant petit alors la montée pas je suis
encore d'accord avec le mois de 2012
ils sont terrifiés même encore
aujourd'hui j'ai peur promet de belles
vacances par dessus tout bientôt vidéo
bien fun en cours de claude à une vidéo
c'est quand upload une vidéo qui va
bideo j'avais un casque de triton les
vrais savent les gamer de l'époque vous
souvenez et les tritons les casques qui
coûtait beaucoup trop cher pour ce que
c'était mais on les prenait quand même
pour montrer qu'on était des gros gamers
j'aime la musique car elle permet de
s'évader mais elle permet aussi d'être
encore plus mal qu'on ne l'est déjà valu
cas ils découvrent les petites peines de
coeur là où il écoute les les petites
chansons de james brown et sam et encore
plus au fond du tout et fait un petit
tweet pour témoigner de ce sentiment ce
moment tu n'as absolument rien à faire
et que tu bad et que tu veux pas te
coucher car pour toi c'est mickey ta
soirée hashtag twitter mais c'était
vraiment mon journal intime quoi twitter
c'est marrant comme ça a changé je vois
pas beaucoup de gens utilisent twitter
un journal intime tout le monde a vite
compris que c'était pas le bon plan du
tout et 70 certaines 77 personnes qui
étaient vraiment d'accord avec ça le
coup de déprime du dimanche pas où tu
repenses à tout un week-end en te disant
c'était énorme passé trop vite devant la
cour les mecs mon twitter l'époque c'est
vraiment moi qui constataient des trucs
dans la vie et qui avait besoin de le
dire un sur twitter comme ça elle
d'aller lui j'ai constaté ça je suis
mature et plus gros que je ne lui paraît
n'est ce pas certains d'entre vous
n'aime pas les vidéos à plusieurs mais
elle reste en minorité j'adore les faire
le plaisir avant tout ok ba aujourd'hui
celle inverse des gens adorent les
vidéos à plusieurs peut-être qu'à
l'époque les gens aimés - ça c'est vrai
non non c'est fini
non alors j'aurais aimé que j'en ai
encore au moins 45 pas bon les amis ya
plus de tweets à regarder au pire vous
allez vous
il ya encore tout ça sur mon fil twitter
j'ai rien vous pouvez aller voir
j'espère car rien de celle où j'ai
l'impression que c'est très narcissique
ce genre de vidéo mais en fait je trouve
ça génial de montrer à quel point les
choses changent les choses évoluent à
quel point c'était une autre époque
aussi avec un autre contexte vous avez
une utilisation twitter comme elle est
différente demain enfin il ya beaucoup
de choses qui ont changé et on se rend
bien compte mais avec ce que je dis
c'est en vie que j'avais aujourd'hui bon
je le savais déjà mais c'est fou comme
tout est allé si vite tout est si vite
parti tout à décoller tout s'est réalisé
entre guillemets sans même je mens enfin
bref je trouve ça très touchant jonquet
un vrai truc intéressant qui montrent
que le temps passe
on change mais qui a des trucs qui
change pas tant que ça je sais pas si
cette vidéo qui sera touchée moi ça m'a
fait plaisir ça m'a beaucoup touché
j'en ai marre de jouer avec ce marteau
mais c'est c'est un toc écoutez
maintenant ça me donne envie de voir
tous les vieux tweets comme ça dépote
youtuber ou même de vous parce qu'on a
un peu grandi ensemble je sais que vous
avez plus ou moins mon âge pour certains
mais je le vois c'est tout là vous avez
fait à l'époque ressort télé s'il vous
plaît c'est un plaisir là haut
bref merci à tous jetés moi comment
conclure je suis très maladroit non
c'est trop chez moi parce que je suis
encore ému je vous propose donc que
cette boîte à meuh face la conclusion de
cette vidéo pour moi on y va ça je ne
sais plus utiliser de boîtes à meuh
[Musique]
salut salut